Now that we have some basic familiarity with d3's basic functionality,
we can begin creating more interesting visualizations, and start applying some
of the things we learned earlier in the lesson with regards to visual encodings.
To start inserting some SVG elements into this page,
we might have to make some room.
As it stands,
it looks pretty cluttered with all of the other elements on the page.
Since you probably want to watch the instructional video of me guiding you
through this, let us try not to remove the video frame element.
There does, however, seem to be a sidebar with the discussion that
we might be able to temporarily make our canvas.
Let's now clear this side column inspecting the element we can scroll up
until we hover over the correct element that highlights the entire box.
In this case, it's a div, but
going even higher you can see there's another div with class call-access-three.
Selecting this element we can inspect what is returned and
indeed again it is the correct element.
If we want to wholesale remove this element we can call d3's.remove function,
but since we actually want to insert some SVG and SVG elements into it,
we only want to remove it's contents.
The dot HTML method defined on its selection either returns the inner HTML of
a selection, in this care here you can see a string of HTML, or if we patch
in an argument it replaces that string of HTML with that value you pass in.
In this case, since we want to empty out the selection,
you simply pass in the empty string.
And as you can see here, the discussion has disappeared and
the DOM elements have been removed from the selection.
Again, if you'd like to know more about the methods and
functions defined on selections or any d3 object,
I suggest looking at the API documents that are linked in the instructor notes.